Yeah.
Can you share with us your reading habits?
Max says,
I'm sorry I'm skipping over some questions
but I have to answer some easier ones
because I'm out of the capacity
to answer difficult ones.
Okay.
I'll answer this one instead.
If you could talk to
Donald Trump for a day,
what would you try to say
or convinced them about?
I don't think I would try to
convince them about things.
I don't actually try to
convince people about things.
I don't think I tried to ask them.
I'd ask him a whole bunch of questions.
I try to figure out how we thought
cause I'm really curious about that.
I'd ask them all sorts of questions,
ask,
see if I could find out what he was up to.
I'd like to know what he's aiming at.
I'd like to know why he
thinks he became president,
what he did right,
what he did wrong,
what,
what he dreads,
like what he would consider
a catastrophic failure,
where he thinks his
biggest weaknesses are,
what he'd like to leave as a,
as a legacy.
Um,
okay.
That would be fascinating.
But see,
I find generally speaking,
it's much more interesting
to ask people questions,
especially people like that,
than ever to try to
convince them of things.
Because the thing is,
I already know what I know,
but I have no idea what he
knows or what he's like.
And so it'd be amazing to
be able to talk to them.
And so I have a bit of that opportunity
now in Canada because I've been speaking
to a lot of political figures in Canada.
I'm going to have that
opportunity in Europe.
But a lot of,
a lot of what you want to do when you
meet people is ask them questions because,
you know,
they'll tell you all sorts
of things you don't know.
And,
um,
that's also an entry point to a really
good conversation is to ask questions.
So that's what I would do.
I'd ask questions like mad
until he chased me away.
So,
okay.